today's data shows that 1 million one
hundred and twenty nine thousand nine
hundred and seven tests for coronavirus
have now been carried out in the United
Kingdom including a hundred and five
thousand nine hundred and thirty seven
tests carried out yesterday a hundred
and eighty two thousand two hundred and
sixty people have tested positive that's
an increase of four thousand eight
hundred and six cases since yesterday
fourteen thousand six hundred and ninety
five people are currently in hospital
with coronavirus down fifteen thousand
one hundred and eleven from the previous
day and sadly of those tested positive
for current virus across all settings
twenty eight thousand 131 have now died
that's an increase of 621 fatalities
since yesterday these are heartbreaking
losses for every family affected and all
our thoughts and prayers are with their
families and their friends Jenny will
provide an update on the latest data on
coronavirus but first as community
secretary I want to update on the steps
we're taking to protect some of the most
vulnerable people in our society as the
Prime Minister set out this week we've
now passed the peak of the virus and he
will provide more details on how we will
address the second phase of this battle
next week we all know that the
restrictive measures as necessary and as
life-saving as they are are difficult
for everyone all of you watching at home
this afternoon have made sacrifices big
and small
and I want to thank you once again for
all that you're doing you're helping us
as a country to turn the tide on the
virus but some in our society for some
in our society these measures involve
sacrifices that none of us would wish
anyone to bear for victims of domestic
abuse
it means being trapped in a nightmare
the true evil of domestic abuse is that
it leaves vulnerable people including
children living in fear in the very
place where they should feel most safe
and secure inside their own home though
domestic violence can leave physical
masks the true extent of the inflicted
pain is much deeper than those marks it
can be invisible these are emotional
scars and scars that for some will never
heal and which can even pass to the next
generation
whose young eyes see things that they
never should and hear things that none
of us would wish our children to witness
as a father of three girls I cannot even
imagine women and young children being
put in this situation but they are and
we must be alive to the reality of what
is happening in all too many homes
across the country I want us to defend
the rights of those women and those
children wherever we can and that is
what we're going to do and this is not a
crime inflicted solely on women it
affects men too this government has
already prioritized tackling domestic
abuse the domestic abuse bill which had
its second reading in Parliament last
week is a landmark piece of legislation
which will create the first-ever legal
definition of domestic abuse and this is
important because it holds those
responsible to account and gives those
suffering at the hands of others more
confidence that action will be taken and
perpetrators brought to justice today I
can confirm that through the domestic
abuse bill the government will also be
ensuring that the victims of domestic
violence get the priority need status
that they need to access local housing
services much more easily this is a
fully funded commitment which will mean
that no victim of domestic violence has
to make the unbearable choice between
staying somewhere that they know is
unsafe or becoming homeless this
government has been clear that we are
determined to break the silence that
samara that surrounds victims to stamp
out the stigma and to strengthen our
support for survivors we've already
announced an extra 15 million pounds to
strengthen our support and an extra 16
million pounds is going directly to
refuge services but we recognize the
extra pressures that are being created
due to covert 19 and that that
necessitates more support while the
necessary social distancing measures
remain in place it is harder than before
for victims of domestic abuse to reach
out to their friends to their family to
colleagues and to neighbors for the
support that they urgently need today I
can announce a package of over 76
million pounds in new funding to support
the most vulnerable in society during
the pandemic this funding will help
charities support of survivors of
domestic and sexual abuse it will
support vulnerable children and their
families and he'll support victims of
modern slavery this additional support
ensure more safe spaces and
accommodation for survivors of domestic
abuse and their children and the
recruitment of additional counselors for
victims of sexual violence and this
funding will also help frontline
charities to be able to offer different
ways of supporting those in need
including virtual or phone based
services we know that some refuges have
had to reduce or even to cancel the
services that they would want to provide
during the pandemic this funding will
help them to meet the challenges posed
in this national emergency and to
continue to help those that desperately
need support I'd like to say a word of
thanks to domestic abuse charities who
are doing so much at this time to help
so many people
the women's aid refuge in my
constituency is one example and I'd like
to thank Marlene and her amazing team in
Newark people like that do incredible
work and deserve all our thanks and
gratitude now more than ever before
where refugees don't have enough
capacity to support those in need during
the pandemic some have asked us if they
could use hotels or other accommodation
nearby on a temporary basis for example
as move on accommodation where they
judge it to be safe and appropriate to
do so we will work with refugees to make
this option available to them if they
judge it to be the right one where it's
necessary